tonight it will be kyle uh cal cuantro
and it's it'll be his second start this
year his first one with the indians
first time he's ever faced the white sox
so he'll beat 50 55 pitches maybe
hopefully three innings
first pitch tim anderson on the ground
left side that's an infield single for
ta and a good start to tonight's ball
game
right field
meek wood has it one down
grounded to third abrayu
is going to bang into a double play and
that will end the inning lopez trying to
do exactly what he's done the last two
starts which has been thrown very well
on for the seventh time his era about
five and a half
high fastball level to left and eloy
jimenez for out number one
that'll bring up cesar hernandez switch
hitting second baseman swung on hit high
hit deep to right it's got a chance it
is gone
cesar hernandez
it's his third home run
and the indians lead it one to nothing
[Applause]
robert in center in the glow of the
cleveland sun for route number two
3-2
robert
is there to make the cash field the ball
shoots through the infield it's a great
offensive part
straw came out looking with a good
fastball
oh he went fishing that time
and cuantro strikes him out he fans two
in the inning they'll want him to start
a clue remember andre he was ready so
quickly after his first start i mean
they said hey man you got to stay out
there get loose yeah he's still fixing
that's it oh maybe i was going to say i
thought that was a pretty good pitch
a reliable arm
whether it's in the spot start situation
or just
coming out of the pull pin i mean he is
just carving off i'm kidding he's going
back out four strikeouts for cal
cointreau as pletco finds himself in big
trouble two on nobody out so luis robert
the batter
god i'm looking painted the fastball
outside corner at the knees they are
loaded with one down and nick madrigal
coming up
here we go though
there's one
and two whoa adam pleco gets out of it
pulled the rabbit out of the hat
struck him out good off speed pitch
third strikeout for lopez quickly the
first two retired here in the sixth and
that'll bring up jose abreu it's one
nothing indians with one swing he could
tie it here
3-2
hit in the air right field side naked
went back at the wall this game is tied
that is his 19th
he now was driven in 56 in this the 55th
game of the year and jose gets it done
he set out to do just that
cody a deep breath three and two
struck him out
in the attic with a fastball
he thinks he's a better pitcher because
of the time they spent them
[Applause]
struck him out
sinker exploded at the bottom of the
zone and this game is tied at one
through seven
are you kidding me
delight on the shields with a tremendous
running catch to steal extra bases away
from adam engel that would have been a
lead off double if not a triple
here's the look going two ramirez runs
check swing ball up he went around
strike three
garrett crochet
carves santana
oh he went wide again and struck him out
so the go ahead run now 90 feet from
home plate with two outs
and the batter is the catcher james
mccann now the payoff swing enemies
whitcrin got him with a slider the
indians
have a shot to get their second walk-off
win and clinch a playoff spot at the
same time at
second 3-2
check swing
he went around says angel hernandez
without an appeal to first base white
sox screaming in their dugout at home
play dump angel hernandez and somebody's
just been ejected from the game
i don't know if it was renoria or tim
anderson
[Applause]
tim anderson was really barking and now
renaria has been ejected so
it must have been tim anderson it was
somebody from the dugout and then
renaria was a little late to get there
to protect whoever it was
james at second base best way to get
your frustration out is to take the lead
adam left field that's a base head up
the alley way
sucks take the lead adam to second base
he's going for third he is safe it's an
rbi triple and a two one sox
go get him 15.
no angle on a ground ball either
bouncing ball through like you said
madrigal beats the infield drawn in it
is three to one sucks
one two
in the air from naylor short center
field sanchez back yomer over the
shoulder
what a play by omar sanchez
see
that was a change center field back is
robert at the wall he leaps up can't
make the play scoring is roberto perez
and into second base with the tying run
as francisco lindor he just missed tying
this game up couldn't ask for anything
better if you're the indians you've got
your best hitter at the plate with a
chance to win it with two out in the
bottom of the tent a swing of the drive
to deep right center field away back and
gone
it's a game winner it's a playoff
clincher
and for the fourth time
in the last five years
indians fans you will have a post season
to remember
a walk off three run homer to right
center by jose ramirez